on sait que les américains bombardent de
l'afghanistan mais là également de
l'aide humanitaire un sujet très
controversé d'ailleurs critiqué par bon
nombre d'organisations humanitaires qui
parle de dangereux mélange des genres
d'autres s'interrogent même sur la
composition de ces colis qui
comprendrait du beurre de cacahuète un
produit dont on imagine qu'il n'est pas
très répandue en afghanistan en tout cas
dans un camp de réfugiés du nord ouest
du pays nous envoyés spéciaux ont pu
constater de quelle manière les sacs
enveloppant la nourriture sont récupérés
par les enfants de réfugiés une
utilisation inattendu claude sans père
pascal quint
voici le nouveau sac d'écolier des
enfants du camp de réfugiés de la laguna
ici à rien ne se perd et certains petits
malins ont vite compris comment il
pouvait utiliser des sacs qui contenait
du encore deux jours les rations
alimentaires envoyés par les américains
tous ces enfants quittent leur camp
chaque matin pour venir à l'école mais
aujourd'hui plusieurs étaient très fiers
d'arborer leur nouveau cartable
l'école est ouverte depuis deux mois
grâce à l'aide d'une organisation
humanitaire à tête et grâce au
cofinancement du gouvernement tue
tous ces enfants ont fui avec leurs
familles les zones de combat avec
hitler jour ils sont venus dans notre
village dit celui-ci ils ont brûlé nos
maisons on est parti dans la nuit
les talibans sont arrivés chez nous dit
noureddine il voulait prendre les
enfants comme moi à partir de 10 ans
pour aller se battre avec eux et si on
refusait il demandait de l'argent de
parler
ces enfants ont tous la même histoire
cette école représente pour une sorte de
refuge un espace de paix et de calme
jour après jour leur professeur tente de
leur expliquer ce qui se passe
actuellement en afghanistan
qui sont les talibans dit le proviseur
ils le savent car ils ont eu leur
village attaqué et brûlé moi j'essaye
aujourd'hui de leur parler de l'action
des américains pour libérer le pays
l'après-midi et l'école accueille les
petites filles
elle porte le voile comme leur
profession en zone talibane depuis 1996
l'éducation est interdite pour les
villes ici dans le nord de l'afghanistan
elles peuvent apprendre à lire et à
écrire en toute liberté
j'obtempère bonjour c'est vous qui
venait de réaliser ce reportage convient
de regarder on a toutes les raisons de
craindre d'énormes problèmes avec les
réfugiés fuyant les combats problème
d'alimentation mais aussi problèmes de
climat l'hiver s'approche contrairement
à ce qu'on pourrait penser en
afghanistan
effectivement l'hiver arrive ici fin
novembre c'est à dire dans mon âme mois
et demi et parfois plutôt dans des
endroits plus élevés de l'afghanistan à
l'heure actuelle ici honorable
réunissant vous le voyez sur cette image
il fait très beau la journée la
température est fraîche la nuit mais
dans un mois un mois et demi ici partout
autour de moi il y aura de la neige
beaucoup neige le cas à l'heure actuelle
beaucoup d'inquiétude par rapport au
sort des réfugiés vous savez qui hier un
responsable de l'unicef à islamabad a
déclaré que cent mille enfants
pourraient mourir dans cet hiver si une
aide massive une aide de grande ampleur
n'arrivait pas de toute urgence en
afghanistan il a dit si elle n'arrive
pas dans les six semaines qui viennent
donc à l heure actuelle en afghanistan
beaucoup d'inquiétude par rapport au
sort des réfugiés pour être tout à fait
précis faut distinguer ici deux zones le
nord afghanistan nous nous trouvons
c'est une zone contrôlée par les forces
de l'ex commandant massoud c'est une
zone où l'aide humanitaire à l'heure
actuelle peut arriver et elle arrive
tous les jours ici mais dans zone
talibane plus au sud du pays à kaboul à
kandahar les organisations humanitaires
ne peuvent travailler qu'avec leur
personnel local tous les expatriés ont
été expulsés depuis le début du conflit
et à l'heure actuelle aucune aide
supplémentaire ne peut arriver dans
cette zone donc vous le comprenez à
l'heure actuelle il ya beaucoup
d'inquiétudes il ya quelques instants on
discutait avec une responsable
responsable d'une organisation
humanitaire et nous parlait justement de
ces largages des avions américains et
nous disait comment on peut lutter
contre l'hiver qui arrive comment on
peut lutter contre la sécheresse dans
les zones où elle sévit avec ses petits
sacs jaunes avec du beurre de cacahuète
avec des haricots avec un peu de lait un
peu de farine ça ne sert à rien nous
disait-il donc à l'heure actuelle
beaucoup d'inquiétudes et beaucoup de
colère